- Hello.
- Hi.
I am so excited to meet you.
- Oh, really?
- Yes, so excited.
- [Kelly] Oh, I hope I don't let you down.
- I love your music and you.
- Okay.
I was like, well meet Djimon.
- It's so great to meet you, too.
- Nice to meet you.
- Miranda.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- So what do you love about
Mission Unstoppable, though?
This is really cool what you're doing.
This is with Geena Davis, right?
- Yes, it's just, it's really fun.
It's my first time hosting a show.
It's all about bringing
STEM to young girls
and letting them know
that it's actually something
they can be a part of.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
Seeing yourself;
that's like what you were
talking about with your son,
like seeing yourself and
then you can achieve it.
Same thing for young girls,
that people don't really drill that in,
like science and everything.
As a host, do you feel like
you learn stuff as well?
'Cause I--
- All the time.
- As a host for this show,
I'm like, I learn stuff all the time.
I think that's like the
coolest part of the job.
- Yeah.
I didn't even realize, it really,
even though I'm an adult
and the show is for kids,
it's made me love science in
a way that I never did before.
So, it kind of did for me
what it's supposed to do for the viewers.
- Yeah, and I know it's for children,
but I bet you most adults,
it's like Smarter Than A Fifth Grader.
I bet you most of us don't know.
- I definitely feel like that when I'm,
when I'm hosting.
I'm like, I never knew any of this.
- Yeah.
I think it's really cool.
It is interesting though,
later in life how you get more
interested in the history channel.
You get more interested in science.
It's almost backwards.
When you're a kid,
all you wanna do is run
outside and adventure
and it's almost like backwards.
I don't know why, how we fix that.
I don't know.
- Yeah.
- So, Miranda, I heard
you had a very specific
favorite science subject as a kid.
- Yes.
So when I was a kid,
I was super into bugs,
which everyone thought was
weird when I was little.
- That's not weird, yeah.
- I was obsessed with bugs.
I loved doing experiments.
I would always get, you
know, the butterflies
how you watch them.
- Yeah.
- Go from caterpillars, turn in--
- [Kelly] Yes, metamorphosis, yeah.
- And this is my millipede.
I had a millipede for five years.
- [Kelly] No, like you
were really into bugs.
- I was into it.
- Yeah.
- Millie the millipede.
- That is, Millie.
Oh, you shoulda had another one, Vanilli.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, that's amazing.
So wait, you're younger,
you're too young for that joke.
I hear that you're obsessed
with cats now, right?
- [Miranda] Yes.
- So you can't have that
around your house then.
- I love animals.
- They'll eat it.
- I'm always trying to get
them to do animal segments
on Mission Unstoppable
on the science show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Constantly I'm always like,
anything that has to do with animals.
But, yeah.
- You so do love animals.
- I love cats and I foster
cats and I recently,
'cause it's been raining a lot in L.A.,
I recently, a cat appeared
on my porch in the rain
and I thought I was doing this great thing
by taking it to a rescue
and then I found out it had a microchip
and lived like a block from my house.
- Oh.
You like, took someone's cat.
- Exactly.
So I had to go back to the
rescue, pick the cat up,
and like awkwardly bring
it back to its family.
So I basically just stole a cat.
- You stole a cat.
- Yeah.
- That's incredible.
Okay, well other than that,
while you're doing Mission Unstoppable,
what's the coolest science fact
that you've found from the show?
- Well, I've experienced
sleep paralysis before.
I don't know if that's
ever happened to you guys.
- What does that mean?
- It's where you wake up,
your eyes are open and
you're lying in bed,
but you're asleep.
So, your dreams that you're having
seem like they're happening
in the room you're in,
like your eyes are open
but you can't move.
- That, that's terrifying.
Have you ever experienced that or do you?
- I've experienced something similar,
but I'm not sure if it's quite the same.
But yeah, there's something--
- What similar?
Like insomnia, or?
- Well, I'm not quite
sure, but it seems like,
yeah, I was asleep briefly,
but I was wide awake.
My eyes are open, I'm yelling to the sky.
I'm completely paralyzed in
the bed and can't move and--
- No, I think that's kind of exactly
like what she just said.
- That's it, that's exactly it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It sounds terrifying, yeah.
- Yeah, it's so scary
and we did this whole segment
on it and it was crazy.
They're talking about how
the best thing you can do
is have a really set sleep schedule
and try to really stick to it.
'Cause it usually happens
when you're stressed or really tired.
- Oh my God.
That's the, it's like
the most annoying thing
a doctor can tell me.
- [Miranda] I know.
Try to sleep perfectly.
- Are you stressed?
And I'm like, am I breathing?
I'm like--
- Yeah.
- There's a lot on the plate.
I'm like, yeah, there's no
button for it, but okay.
But I've never experienced that,
so maybe I'm doing all right.
- Yeah, I think you're doing good.
- Because if I were, yeah,
I think that would, I think,
God knows I can't handle that.
So you're turning, is
it 30, in a few weeks?
- Yes, I am.
- [Kelly] That's exciting.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
- My twenties, I felt like
were really hard, although fun.
There were great moments,
but my thirties were like way better.
Are you excited about your thirties?
- I am excited about my thirties.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I hear that from everybody that
it's even better than the
twenties, so I'm ready.
- And honestly now I'm, I
just turned 40 this past year.
So like, 40 is the same thing.
I think it, I don't know how you feel,
but I feel like life gets
better the older I get.
- Oh, for sure.
- Maybe you mature or something.
- For sure.
- Yeah.
- Maturity makes you
enjoy and relax about--
- Wiser about things.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Do you have any plans for your birthday?
- I am actually going to be
in Thailand for my birthday.
- [Kelly] What?
- For the first time
ever, I've never been.
- For work or pleasure, or both?
- It's for a Netflix movie, but my,
some of my friends are gonna
fly out for my birthday,
so, I'm so excited.
- That's so cool.
Have you ever been to Thailand?
- I've never been before.
I'm going to Phuket.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I love Thailand.
Have you ever been to Thailand?
- Yes, I filmed there once.
- It's really, really cool.
I love it.
The little markets.
- Did you stay for a while when you went?
- I did.
I'm always, it's always around work.
Like, it's like if I'm touring,
I think I was touring there
or doing like MTV Asia Awards.
I can't remember what I was doing there.
I've been there a few
times but I, but I love it.
I love the people, they're so kind.
I love, I think they call
them tuk-tuks or something.
Like they drive you--
- Tuk-tuk, yeah.
- Tuk-tuk, tuk-tuk.
That's what it is.
They're in like the bicycles
and they drive you around everywhere.
That was the first time.
- Oh, cool.
- I was like, I just like
saying, "Can I get a tuk-tuk?"
Like I just like saying it.
- I'm gonna say that as soon as I land.
- Don't say, "took took"
'cause I mispronounced it.
Tuk-tuk, okay.
Well it is great that
you're doing iCarly again.
Did you think you would
ever do this again?
Like a reboot?
- I didn't.
(audience cheers)
- Yeah?
It's such a popular show.
- Yeah, it's been so much fun.
We just finished the third season
and there's this whole love story
that's been going on on the show
since I was 13 when I first started it
between my character Carly and
my friend Freddie on the show
and this whole season is all
about like, our love, so.
- I love that.
- It's been a fun season and--
- What a cool thing with a cast
to like know since you were a kid, right?
And growing up?
That's kind of cool.
- Yeah, we really grew up
together, so it's crazy.
Like Nathan, who plays
Freddie on the show,
has like two daughters now and is married
and it's just crazy.
- So different.
- Being with someone your whole life,
like hanging out with someone
like that, it's really nice.
- Yeah.
Well the original show
was for tweens and teens,
but do you ever get parents like saying,
"Oh my God, I love your show"?
Because as a parent, I've
actually watched the show
with kiddos before and it's kind of cool
when you make a show that
parents can sit there
with their kids and watch
and you like it as well.
You know, you're not like, oh this again.
You know, like that's kind of cool.
Do you ever hear from
parents, in that sense?
- Yeah, sometimes parents
will come up to me
and it's really nice
'cause now that the show
is for the original viewers
and they've all grown up.
- Yeah.
- They, a lot of people will
come up to me and say like,
"I'm 30 now and I've been
watching it with my dad again,"
or like, "I've been watching
it with my mom again."
- Yeah.
- And that feels really good,
like, it's something they
did when they were young
and now they can do it
again with their family.
- Yeah, you're getting,
helping people connect.
- It's really nice.
- That's cool, yeah.